(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] This is a story about a farm.
Not just any farm,
but a place where imagination
sprouts up the soil.
- We grow really kooky, weird,
wild, wonderful, tasty stuff.
Honestly, the weirder the better.
- Like what?
- Mashua,
oca,
Badger flame beet.
squashini,
Butterfly sorrel,
Sunset sorrel,
pichuberries,
pineberries,
white alpine strawberries,
ice plant.
- Wait, what was the last one?
- What you never heard of ice plant?
- [Narrator] Uh, no.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Meet Aaron Choi.
Aaron never had any intentions
of getting into farming.
- I had actually planned
to grab a Master's
and then my PhD in
order to teach the study
of religion in college.
I took a complete 180.
- [Narrator] That 180 is
thanks to his parents.
After running a successful flower shop,
Aaron and his sisters tried
to get them to retire.
But his parents had other plans.
- Their retirement was
to go buy a farm instead.
- They started off
growing Korean vegetables
for retail markets.
But then Aaron got involved,
and things took a turn for the bizarre.
- After I got started getting
my hands dirty pulling weeds,
obsessing over growing conditions,
light, water, temperature,
humidity everything around it,
it just became one elevated experiment
after another; and I think
that's where I was hooked.
And all of that rang and
resonated far better with me
than sticking my nose
in books all the time,
quite frankly.
- [Narrator] Once he familiarized himself
with farm life he took the R&D
to another level.
- We started experimenting with
a lot of different greens.
Then, that very quickly
blew off into a whole host
of other relatively unfamiliar products
like Pichu Berries,
Sweet Jade green tomatoes,
which nobody's heard of,
and my favorites,
oka and Mashua, which even fewer people
have heard of let alone actually tasted.
The goal has always been to target, first
and foremost, high-end restaurants
because I think that there's a lot
of trickle down effect on
new and strange ingredients.
- [Narrator] So how does one pivot
from selling bulk retail items
to supplying fancy high-end restaurants?
- I literally started making cold visits.
Once the chefs started
seeing what we were growing,
to my surprise they were blown
away by the quality of it.
I regularly get comments
like, I can't believe you're growing this.
- Good?
- Yeah.
- Tart?
- Sweet.
- Good.
It's the specialty side
where my obsession fits in line
with trying to familiarize the unfamiliar.
There's a lot to be said about
these unfamiliar foods of the world
that we really need to
introduce more people to.
Because the more we popularize,
the more conversations happen
around those foods;
without food we don't have conversation.